- So we've depicted here the area under
the curve F of X above the X-axis,
between the points X
equals A and X equals B.
And we've denote it as the definite
integral from A to B of F of X, DX.
Now what I wanna do with
this video is introduce
a third value, C, that
is in between A and B.
And it could be equal to A
or it could be equal to B.
So let me just introduce
it, right, just like that.
And I could write that A
is less than or equal to C,
which is less than or equal to B.
And what I wanna think
about is, how does this
definite integral relate to
the definite integral from
A to C and the definite
integral from C to B.
So let's think through that.
So we have the definite
integral from A to C of F of X.
Actually I've already used
that purple color for the
function itself, so we use green.
So we have the integral
from A to C of F of X, DX,
and that of course is
going to, that's going to
represent this area right
over here, from A to C under
the curve F of X, above
the X-axis, so that's that.
And then we can have the integral from
C to B of F of X, DX,
and that of course is
going to represent this
area right over here.
Well the one thing that
probably jumps out at you
is that the entire area from
A to B, this entire area
is just a sum of these two smaller areas.
So this is just equal to
that plus that over there.
And once again, you might say,
"Why is this integration property useful?"
That if I found a C that is in
this interval that's greater
than or equal to A and it's
less than or equal to B, "Why
"is it useful to be able to
break up the integral this way?"
Well as you'll see this is
really useful, it can be
very useful when you're
doing disc, when you're
looking at functions that
have discontinuities,
if they have step
functions you can break up
the larger integral
into smaller integrals.
You'll also see that this
is useful when we prove
the fundamental theorem of Calculus.
So in general, this is actually a
very, very, very useful technique.
Let me actually draw an
integral where it might be
very useful to utilize that property.
So if this is A, this is B,
and let's say the function,
I'm just gonna make it
constant over an interval.
So it's constant from there
to there, and then it's,
and then it drops down
from there to there.
Let's say the function looked like this.
Well you could say that the
larger integral, which would be
the area under the curve,
it would be all of this.
Let's just say it's a gap right
there or it jumps down there.
So this entire area you
can break up into two,
you can break up into two smaller areas.
So you could break that up into that area
right over there, and then this area right
over here using this integral property.